welcome back to tech net radio the
microsoft research connections team
joins us for today's episode as dr.
kristen toll and Chris went walks us
through the debut of the Microsoft
translator hub to nana's a discussed
what it is how it works as well how it's
powered by Windows Azure and Windows 8
PC clusters and what its impact is and
how we communicate with each other on a
global scale blame the micro shores
hello and welcome to IT time i'm your
host blame Barden a senior i keep early
evangelists here at Microsoft in my
Tampa studio you're in sunny Florida and
with me they have two special guests on
IT time dr. Kristen toll I do Kristin
good thank you get in Chris wet how you
doing Chris Blair well thank elope
welcome to the show so I'd like to start
with Kristen first you're the director
of natural interactions into microsoft
research connections team that's correct
yeah that's right at a clinical
associate professional university of
washington famous University of
Washington Huskies I am a cougar awesome
perversity but can't we always get along
so so great since joining microsoft dr.
toll has acquired several patents in
working several product teams including
a natural language group visual studio
excel prior to joining microsoft you are
a research associate at the university
of arizona artificial intelligence lab
managing a team of researchers working
on medical information retrieval natural
language processing that's pretty cool
in their area is it looks like you have
included ear research global public
health contextual computing natural
language processing the machine
translation mobile computing which is a
hot topic these days user intent
modeling maybe to talk about some of
these and the democratization that is
and so we'll get to get to a couple of
really specific questions for you but
i'm going to turn that over to talk
about Chris per minute chris is a
principal program manager research
machine translation went to the
university of hamburg germany
subsequently spent a decade on software
internationalization a multitude of of
our microsoft products including windows
force internet explorer and i send when
live bringing those products to market
with equal functionality worldwide since
Chris joined Microsoft it says 2005 is
the leading the program management
planning for Microsoft machine
translation development responsible for
being translator at school and Microsoft
translator services new Basin
headquarters red so great cress break
Kristin let's move back to dr. tool I
have a question all right it's a special
question it's a question I always ask my
guests when they join I tee time and
that was tell me tell us all with your
first computer experiences um I started
out actually as an unread and I thought
I was going to become an accountant and
I decided that was really terribly
boring but it's going through that
program I was forced to take a computing
class and I was just so thrilled with
the back but I had so much control over
a system that I went on to get my
bachelor's in science and then my
master's of science and even a PhD it
just never stopped that's that's great
you know seem to be a very knowledgeable
in all the different artificial
intelligence stuff running the lab
managing a team of researchers that's
pretty neat can you tell me like your
first career experience then like how
did you get started in IT what brian is
always well because I was already in
accounting and just taking computing
classes that were in association with it
I really got a very firm grounding and
business computing at the same time I
played around in the evening with
hacking and so what ended up happening
is I got caught which means I wasn't
obviously this good of a hacker's I
thought it was and got suspended from
using any internet-connected system for
a year but at the end of it they hired
me on as their computer systems operator
at the University wow what a story I
don't know if that's great or not but it
kind of leapfrog to right into your
career in all the wonderful things you
your curses yeah so you know back over
to Chris what brought you and it you
know what was your first computer
experience the kind of wood what brought
you tonight oh and I'm afraid to answer
it because it because it dates me I tell
you what my first computer was you know
how old I am or when I when I got
started in this for my first computer
was a sharp MGA dai I i bought it just
out of the out of a whim it was
affordable at the temblor was way before
the IBM PC or the the pc area as we know
it today and it didn't have any any mass
storage except for tape drive and I i
started out programming little games in
in basic which was the which was built
into the into the device and that's what
you could that's what you could do so
and i tried it down with my with my
friends and they wrote little games and
that was kind of the activity that that
one did with these with these pcs other
than then automating different home
control activities or managing your
recipes or something like that we didn't
talk about connections that I raval
stand alone and it was not what not
exactly connectable to anything and yeah
programming games was was really a fun
activity but I grew out of it pretty
soon and and and but it was the reason
for me to decide that I didn't want to
pursue a career in law or diplomacy
there was my my my target up to them
before and and decided computers that's
what I wanted to do and I upgraded to a
to a new new machine pretty soon after
that it wasn't an apple to clone and
accordingly for the real the real one so
I bought a table to clone they didn't
work very well this epitope clones so so
you needed to reboot really really
really frequently and their ball that's
that's all right I pretty soon I decided
then to to study computer science and
and that firmly firmly embedded me in
the field
at of course you can you can notice that
that English isn't by is my first
language and so coming here to Microsoft
are pretty much as quickly zoomed into
working on internationalization making
making making our software work across
language and country boundaries and
that's and that's a very interesting
field and it's that something where
Microsoft is is traditionally good at
and and well I'm still there hey I think
that's fantastic in specially when we
talk about globalization of the
languages of all the different products
that we have all the documentation all
the bits and bytes you know being able
to be in you know in the German version
of Windows a vehicle that you make a
change in Active Directory have a show
up and English on the other side of you
the integration of all these different
bits and bytes and how they interrelate
it's just it's quite amazing so I'm very
pleased to have both that you want this
show today we're going to talk about
Microsoft translator hub translation I
guess I'll stope enough for for the
first question either one of you Kristen
Chris would want to take this one is is
you know why is why is what is Microsoft
translator first of all and why is it
Orton's yeah I talk about Marcus off
translator in general at this point so
master translator has been has been
available as a web service for a while
simply what it does you give it a piece
of text in one language and you'll get
it back in another language that's the
best really the whole secret has secret
to the service and we have a bunch of
our own UI on top of that if you go to
bing translator for instance you can
just type some text and have it all copy
and paste it and there and and get it
translated you can use this day the
functionality from within office from
within link from him within mess msi
messenger you can use it on third party
sites like facebook for instance you can
you can have your messages or can see
the messages post
it by by other people in a different
language you can see it in your language
and well facebook for instant all these
applications they use the Microsoft
translator API and the API does the
basic functionality that I just
described you give it as you give it a
string in one language and they
translates it into a a different
language if you have used used any of
these services before you know that the
translations aren't perfect they are
automatically generated based on machine
learning technology that we have
implemented on our site that learns from
existing translated material it will
deduct it will it will then generate a
set of mappings out of that is all
statistically improbable istic so the
more you read the more confidence you
get that a certain translation is good
and obviously we can translate commonly
used phrases and and words very well and
they rarely used once not so well you
would imagine that at one point
everything that can be said has been
translated that's by far not true and
not the case people come up with new
things to say stuff all the time and
it's very very rare that you that you
hit a something that has been said
before exactly again so you need to have
these systems that can deduct knowledge
from existing translations and and and
translate something that hasn't been
seen before into any of their of the
languages that are at this time
supported so the translator supports 37
languages today and and the number of
languages grows all the time as we get
new material that we can train the
system on available to us and then we'll
will feed it to the machine learning
algorithms and they'll they'll learn how
to translate not as good as a human who
is who was able to speak these two
languages but I haven't really found a
human who can translate thirty seven
languages between any of the tool
perfectly well yeah it's uh it's amazing
now I've used the tool Ashley on the on
msn it's a even to just do it as quickly
as it does even when you're talking
about double by characters like kanji r
you know some of those languages it's
it's amazing it really is really you
guys keep perfecting it putting all
those very very smart people behind the
engines optimizes algorithms except
yourself it's phenomenal ah so Kristen
now tell me you know we kind of know I
mean obviously they're there August
benefits here of the Microsoft
translator hub and how it translates
from one language to another but you
know what's the what's this gothon
what's the power behind the energy and
the computing power it presents all this
information yeah what's really unique
and interesting is the new system that
we're coming out with Microsoft
translator hub is that it enables that
kind of customization that Chris is
referring to to happen for any language
at to date we've actually built all of
the language models that we had produced
to date for the first 37 but we now
actually have a hub naval language
that's a long dull and that has been
enabled by the fact that we created what
we call a community portal so this means
that under-resourced languages and
language communities that currently
don't have access to automated
translation can build their own
translation models so they upload their
data they can link their small data to
our big data that's in in Microsoft
translator and create a really robust
translator system for their language and
it all happens in a private workspace
where they can improve that system
crowdsource that system in their
community and then eventually release
that system when they're ready not when
some big company decides that they're
ready so it's just power buys it is it
what does that here is it what's the
what's the back end maybe what are we
what kind of products are we using
unpacking yeah so it is it's it is a web
service powered by user and it's so it's
available in the cloud from anywhere in
the world which also means that it can
work for
kinds of communities as long as they
have access to the internet on the back
end we actually build the language
models on a high-performance computing
cluster here in building 99 and
Microsoft so the beautiful thing about
that is you know a language community is
not going to have and has your server
and they're not going to have you know a
high-performance computing cluster just
on hand so they're literally turning
that sort of computing over to us and
you know we provide the compute power
and they provide the data and together
we build a language yeah that's pretty
cool and what perfect timing that show
the power of the high-performance
computing with that floud motorcycle
engine Arlington I mean it could have
been a perfect time you think for this
for this for the show so so Chris back
to you question for you maybe you can
answer a little bit more about some of
the you know the I've spent I spent
three years international traveling for
Microsoft everywhere big North Americans
but you know good deal of time and
airplanes going to India and China and
knowing you know if you're in Africa
some of the cultural differences their
cultural and length language
preservation and cut it you know
different things and medians mean
different things to different people so
how does the system and how does
Microsoft translator hug deal with
cultural spaces all right let me
differentiate a little bit about
Microsoft translator and Microsoft
translator hub so the minds of
translator hub is a set of features
built on top of of Microsoft translator
the Microsoft runs later back end which
allows this this customization for
specialized domains and areas of
language and style plus it allows
language communities to to build up
support for a new language it isn't
supported yet Microsoft translator
service then is is the infrastructure on
how you use all of this you can use
Microsoft translator with a generic
language support that we that we provide
what we provide is
is doing in a decent job on average on
average content it doesn't do a
particularly good job on your type of
content if you want that then you use
the Microsoft translator hub tell us a
little bit about yourself or the more
you tell us about yourself the the
better job we can do you tell us about
yourself by showing us some of the
material that you have translated before
in your style in your domain using the
terminology that that you prefer and
once you have done that if you have
adopted that this is or adapted to
system to your environment to what you
like to do what you like to translate
and this is how we get the cultural
sensitivity to your your particular
business or interest or our area of
specialization let me give you a couple
examples of areas of specialization that
could be that could be agriculture it
could be brewing like to just appeal to
your interest here or it could be a
automotive or it could be it could be a
computer technical and in fact the the
our history the history of our team here
is that we set out to help Microsoft
translate its own stuff its own software
its own documentation its own blog post
its own kb articles and so so we built a
system that is adapted to the microsoft
culture how microsoft says things in
other in other languages and that's not
always a one-to-one translation you can
you can imagine that the word table
right it can be a sequel table or the
table that you eat on and and both would
be there probably translated in most
language differently right the table
that you eat on a table that sits in a
in a in a sequel database and in English
it happens to be ambiguous write the
word the word table and you have these
ambiguities all the time and that's
that's a it's an aspect of human
language that you can't you can
you can't argue or move away from and so
what these things do is or what our
system does it looks at the context how
what are what are the words that are
surrounding this particular word like
table in the in the context repair that
we are looking at but that is in many
cases not not enough to look just adjust
in that in the near vicinity you'll need
to know more and that's where Microsoft
translator hub comes in allowing you to
tell us hey this is the stuff that I
want to translate and then the hub gives
you a key that you pass into the very
normal Microsoft translator API at epi
Road Microsoft translator calm and it
will refer to the learning that that you
have helped us to do before and it will
use that adaptation to do to give you a
better translation than our generic
service or in or yeah a generic service
would give you and that's that's how we
how we learned stuff if let me talk
about the generic methodology little as
well so then you you asked how do you
bridge the cultural differences and a
and variations it's all based on what
humans did before you what what what we
like as training material is something
that got translated by a qualified human
and so the computer really doesn't
invent much or doesn't invent anything
here sometimes you'd think they'd invent
stuff but but in reality it's not
invented it's based on what it has seen
before what the human has has taught not
necessarily us but has taught at has
taught us via translating a document in
the culturally appropriate way and
that's what we simply reproduce by by
guessing the right context and and using
the appropriate terms that that that a
human has used before
so dr. toll of another question for you
maybe you could answer that there's the
Microsoft translator up enables public
participation the creation of these
types of models that you're working on
otherwise known as crowdsourcing you can
enlighten us little bit about what
crowdsourcing is if how we make the
translator up even better I'm sure I'd
love to cats are thinking really
leverages the world to just chip in
really kind of and take ownership of and
participate in the developing of our
language models what we like to do is we
like to really empower ownership inside
of a language community so that they can
actually build their translations
directly in kind of to play a little bit
off of what Chris was saying earlier
where he was talking about how language
is never constant it's always changing
it you know in order to keep languages
really vibrant it's really to tap into
the community so that we can keep
building more and more recent you know
communication into the translator itself
it's the way to keep the translator more
accurate but it also allows the
community to contribute their
terminology the way they like to say
things and have it change over time and
also creates a vibrancy around it but
you know really the the methodology here
behind it is just that you know we could
go out and scrape a bunch of data and
work in a clock darkroom and come up
with a translation model but instead
what we're doing is we're allowing the
crowd to participate in it we're
allowing them to really be a part of
developing the model deciding when it is
ready even to deploy and I think that's
just a great story so Kirsten I have a
question for you you had mentioned
earlier about cloud-based translation or
using the cloud or the power of Windows
Azure a more public cloud offering
talking about web accessible service
using save standard Microsoft translator
api's HTTP Ajax asp.net and so better
faces as well to a kind of a web page
embedded widget if you will
explain a little bit more about how
we're using our public cloud windows
azure to power the engines behind this
Microsoft translation yeah what it
allows us to do really is take
information from all over the world I
mean you can upload all kinds of
information it's so it's really that
what did the scenario mostly enables is
this globalization of knowledge I mean
there's a huge knowledge base that's on
the internet and we get it tap into that
and make that available in all these
different languages and you know you
mentioned earlier in my bio that I'm i
work for the democratization of medicine
and that's kind of a misnomer I admit
but ultimately what we want to do is we
want to globalize medical information
you know really democratize it so that
we all get the same level of health care
so as long as we have access to the
cloud our information is up there it can
be localized no matter where I am in the
world so that doctors who are treating
me have that information in their
language and could treat me better and
you can see the scenario playing out and
being fully enabled by it by having it
built on Ezer so so let's talk a little
bit more about the futures right I mean
you guys have done a one guys and gals
have done a fantastic job of translating
a page you know with the Bing Translator
or being able to read at different
languages 37 different languages I mean
create huge endeavor on this whole
translation piece you know what is the
future gonna bring us if you can if you
could talk about it and you know share
about maybe this is a better question
for chris is is how what is it going to
bring in the future what's going to
bring us you know 35 years you know yes
we have a pretty good idea where where
where we want to be otherwise I wouldn't
really be here if it was done already I
would work I would work on something
else so no and the other thing is so
automatic translation is an area that is
50 years old I did it started started 50
years ago with the waves and russian to
english translation system is one of the
first known known automatic translation
systems that that exists is so
50 years at you and we have made great
advances since then but it's it's it's
far from being perfect so getting better
is our getting better in translation is
our primary goal and in fact the
Microsoft translator hub is an avenue
down that down that road if you if you
tell us more about yourself as I
mentioned um week we do a better job for
your type of content for your style that
is addressing the quality them the most
apparent quality concern of course we
also like to make that the generic
language ability better so if you if you
assume a non a translator that is not
trained in a particular area but what
knows language well they'll they'll
still do a better job than than we do at
this time but I'd like to to reduce the
number of myths translated sentences and
phrases further and further in doing
that among an ever-growing set of
languages is is the next goal here right
we cover thirty seven languages today
which is a very tiny fraction of the
languages that are spoken on earth I
depends on on how you define but I think
you're relatively good definition brings
us to seven languages that exist that
are being spoken 7,000 plus a seven I
mean 7,000 languages spoken on earth and
37 is really small it covers a pretty
good good portion of the population but
by far not enough in my view and and
that's the other area that we are that
we are investing in and that we want to
bring to fruition and the Magus of
translator hub gives us a good piece of
the methodology by which we can we can
achieve the goal of an abling
communication between and more more and
more people on this planet absolutely
you start looking at just you know like
India along with a couple hundred
different dialects right at different
languages you know
you know from the left to the right or
reading from the right to the left or
starting at the back of the book and
reading to the front of the book or the
front of books at the back of the book
and all these different ways in which we
interpret a language and how we you know
how we analyze and convert if you will
you know complex you know syntax
sentence structures things like that
even it's even in English so big
undertaking it's been jump great
interview today yes can I one can I had
one more topic absolutely so I mentioned
better quality better translation
quality I mentioned more more languages
the other aspect of course is making
this accessible to the people within the
means of of what is available to them
including the application that they are
using the operating system they are
using the device they are using so we
have spent some good amount of effort to
making our API easy to use and universal
and we don't see it used exclusively
through Microsoft's own application
what's available to you for your
application for your device doesn't even
have to run a Microsoft operating system
we like that but if you don't that's
also ok and integrate our servers that
make it available to users within their
workflow within their activity because
translation is no help if it's not
accessible to you and the other aspect
here is that that of course not all not
all material that you want to translate
is available in text form right so the
next the next step here to take is
interpreting speech and and translating
it into a different language to allow
verbal communication that's that's it
easy sound like actual have such you
want to add to that oh I was just saying
everything because this is a machine
learning system I mean it can learn all
kinds of natural language processing
applications this is translation is one
speech is one that that Chris just
mentioned
and you know I was holding up my phone
this is actually a third-party
application that was developed called
polyglot on my windows phone but
immediately that that this application
got a new language added this week just
simply because we added it they didn't
have to change their code at all a new
language gets added and so there's more
functionality in the API is just
automatically for people who develop
against them that's awesome so pretty
over there as far as developed is
concerned hey this has been a great
interview great episode 4i teton dr
crystal toll the Director of National
interaction the microsoft research
connections team and Chris went the
principal group program manager for
research machine translation great topic
it's amazing what we're doing out there
and in research technology with that
where would we go and find the Microsoft
dress it's actually at HTTP hub
Microsoft translator com and if you want
to use the API you can go to api doc
mcstuffins later com excellent perfect
well thanks Kristen doctors at all Chris
wet you guys are awesome love to have
you back on IT times sometime thanks
regarding else I'd love to come back so
like that it's a wrap